Let's strip away all of the madness.
Would you call us friends?
Ugh. Yes.
(laughter)- Come on.
We are we're friends.
We're pals.
We are. -You can plead the fifth on this.
You don't have to answer this.
No, we are
Friends. -Do you understand
that you are like catnip to me?
You're very presence makes me insane.
You've seen it Sonna, right?
You mean it really is.
It's very specific people when
they're around him, he lights
up and then he's like, oh, the
amount of things he can think
of and you know what you, you play
along. And I think it just empowers
Him. - So this is a true story just
before we started this podcast here
at our new podcast studio space here
in Larchmont in Los Angeles.
I see that you've just
entered and you're walking
down towards the podcast
studio and I get so excited.
I turn to Sonna.
Yeah. - Who is eating what?
I was eating some chocolate.
I was eating a crunch bar and
a small Snicker's bar had.
And what did I do?
I was so excited.
This is awful.
In one hand, I had like
a rapper and then you
knock the rapper outta my hand.
And then I grabbed the, the
chocolate outta my mouth.
'cause I'm angry.
Then you knock that out of my hand.
And then you step on it and you laugh
What's a maniac? - Just like
a maniac. - It was the behavior of, look
I am a 44 year old grown man.
Oh sir.
(group laughter)
Oh
(group laughs harder)
Oh, Sir
I am a 78 year old man
that should know better.
And I literally do
become a giddy puppy when
you're around and I behave
in an insane manner.
And I hope you take it as a
compliment that it should be
Love it.
But also again, when you think back
to where you were and where you are
I can't believe like I'm
hanging out with you.
You know, like I used
to watch you on my TV.
You didn't own a
television he's gesturing.
Well, that was your takeaway?
(group laughs)
My takeaway from that
very nice statement was
you didn't own a television.
I no he's being so
nice. - No, no, that was no, listen.
that was, I don't take
it for granted either.
And we went out to dinner.
We won't say with who
very famous comedy person,
just the other night.
(laughter)
You and I had a really nice
Famous people.
dinner the other night with a
a famous person who won't be mentioned.
Right. - But we had a blast with hater.
It was great.
Ah, and was it really
He didn't say first name though.
Oh yeah.
I won't say which hater, but he went
on his way and then I
walked you to your car.
Aw. - And we, we hugged each other.
It was quite late at night.
Yeah. - And I said, I hugged you.
and I went, well, love you Jack.
You didn't say anything in return.
I don't remember that.
You blacked out
Blacked out and you just
let me get behind the
wheel. That's
(group laughter)
He really did that hurt your feelings?
Were you waiting for it? Did it linger?
Knew he couldn't do it.
He's said cartoon mule.
He's not gonna love you this little.
Like he probably first
couldn't even process it was
in denial and then grief and then, or
or making sure that you're being sincere.
Yeah. - Yeah.
Right. Maybe I maybe I've
stung you so many times
that you couldn't.
I think so.
Well, I love hanging out with you.
You are one of my favorite people.
Every time I see you,
this is all as this is
this is as sincere as I can be.
Every time I lay eyes on you.
I am a giddy kid at Christmas
and I love, I don't care.
I know at some point, you
and I are gonna exchange real
information about each other.
cross talk
We did good.
We did good today.
This was today.
We did pretty well.
Today, today was the start.
Today was the start.
You're gonna have to go
through and take through this.
Go find the moments
and string it together.
Like a conversation for real
this will not make sense to anybody.
This is one of the more lucid ones really?
Oh no. - It is pretty good.
But anyway, and before we go, I did want
we have a special surprise guest.
Who?
Your first donkey.
(donkey noise imitation)
Moan, ow.
Outta control.
Oh, I just did it
because I don't know if
they can see your reaction.
This just absolute.
We're all so embarrassed.
Yeah, we really are.
(laugh)
We're all so embarrassed.
We were heading towards a beautiful day.
I can't do it. I can't do it.
Wonderful conclusion.
I'm sorry.
And then brayed like a
donkey, like a donkey.